From everything I've read and heard about breast implants after a mastectomy, it would be greatly I would be greatly concerned about side effects, especially with already having a large autoimmune condition from late stage line. What are your thoughts on this?
I would agree. I understand I'm not a female and it's hard for me to judge the emotional psychological effects of not having a breast or breasts when you have them removed and you want to replace those.
It's hard for me to say that a person shouldn't but from just from a health standpoint, it certainly is not healthy to go and get implants.
I could say that without reservation, does it mean that you shouldn't? No, not saying that but I'm just saying it's not in the person's best health to go and get implants.
You're doing multiple surgeries and to have the skin stretched and to have the implant placed and you have healing that has to take place from that surgery.
The more surgeries that you do, how your body heals from a surgery slash wound is to give off more growth factors.
I've used the example of you just cut yourself, you know, if you cut yourself with a knife by accident, it's amazing how fast your skin heals, but normally your skin cells will replenish themselves on a normal basis about once every three months.
So as the mother cell gives off another cell and it dies, that takes place, but once every three months is the normal apoptotic cycle of your dermis, but if you cut yourself, it's amazingly wounds up scars up and heals within a few days to a week, maybe not completely healed, but it's wounded up so that it's not an open cut in a very short period of time.
Because in a case of an injury, your body gives off growth factor in order to speed up that process of recovery, thereby increasing the growth rate, therefore increasing the replication rate of the cells in order to heal.
Well, the more surgeries that we're going to get, if we already have a circulated tumor cells in the area that were basically spilling gasoline slash growth factor on it, you increase risk of of reoccurrence is there.
I think, yes, you have to weigh it all out of that. Okay, well, I'm going to go crazy and I'm going to feel horrible by myself.
Everybody's going to make their own decisions. I'm just saying from a strict health-related issue, that's one factor that I would recommend against having reconstructive surgery.
And then you bring up the fact that if you already have an autoimmune condition, the possibility of reacting from those silicon plastics that are in that, that implant is there, is real.
It's not just pretend and that can cause issues.
So yeah, I am not a big fan of that, though I know everybody has to make their own decisions there.